c'est parti on y va c'est le toc toc toc
vous connaissez le principe on y va on
va accueillir notre premier johnny toc
toc toc c'est parti c'est dadjo deux
minutes juste
est-ce qu'on n'a pas d'une gueule pour
le tac toc toc est bon avec le jingle
date toute hâte en deux minutes merci
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien tu veux tu parles tu es mon
ami mais ça prend du temps
alors attention a dit tac tac tac sécu
et dadou la duke et joe blairer tonnes
en 2020
arrêté
kenny jamais et carrière compris tu dois
dire d'être autodidacte joue qui tu dois
dida à we had j'oublierai ton nom mais
ces morts ces morts merci les gars là
c'est bon on verra bien la main armée
ainsi cohabiter le jeu c'est le jeu
c'est toc toc toc c'est qui céda djoudj
adérito date j'oublierai viendront sous
la halle un mail à alors allez-y alors
toc toc toc
non mais ça que vous êtes à côté d'un
bon non mixtes et la barre mettez vous
la mettez vous là alors oui alors et
octobre stocks
c'est qui et dadou dazhou qui doublent
irait tendon voilà ça vous apprendra
base au deuxième temps que toc toc c'est
parti cinq attaques d'un mois l'a
reconnu s'agit de verdez ya très peu de
temps en temps c'est gros ce vote
enquête monde amaury
alors attention t'attaquerons fait le
taq taq cette voix sur la tête de ma
mère
on dirait toujours les témoins que ces
anonymes sans rigoler pas fait long feu
et là et fatou patou qui a toute la
musique que j'aime bien le liveview
mais moi c'est réussi pour cette fois ça
c'est johnny vin assez johnny fatto non
mais en plus
regardez moi et non mais quand même
c'est le seul mec regardez ça fait
combien de temps que tu fais de la télé
maintenant ça fait dix ans que je fais
de la télé il est là il est là il rentre
il ya deux caméras et s'ils veulent
garder la bassesse espèces dort mal mais
c'est pas possible et j'ai été obsédé
par vous ah oui bah ne soyez plus ça là
là franchement ça vous va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'y mets tout ça
merci à les attentions pour l'instant je
vous le dis je suis en train de faire je
vais faire moi même mon classement
pour l'instant il est juste devant vous
mais c'est une de mes deux pays ça c'est
une catastrophe
attention c'est parti toc toc toc
ça c'est une voie de marocaine c'est
omar omar khin omar sy situe selon me
paie ses proches n'avaient pas de
perruque barma pas donné
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très à l'aise
obama pas donné allez-y hashtag toc toc
toc nous dit quel est le meilleur toc
toc toc pour le moment pour le meilleur
pour le moment c'est une catastrophe les
trois ouvrages étaient pas mal non non
vous étiez nous sommes quand même vous
êtes très belle en tout cas donc ça
sauve le truc attendait contrairement
aux deux autres
mais bah oui bah oui oui il ya eu au
moins elle artistiquement c'est beau
esthétiquement c'est bon vous voilà
c'est vous chez mais vous depuis quand
jaune il a eu cette coupe mais sans
rigoler sur la tête de ma mère on dirait
un robespierre
[Rires]
pour l'instant je me suis franchement
vous êtes les trois aussi nul dernier
avant dernière et on tp merci du premier
vous êtes antépénultième attention c'est
parti lespwa tu dis pas toc toc toc toc
c'est mal comme adam key buy com vous
donne l'envié l'envié d'avoir envie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi mais c'est nul mais bon là
alors et c'est une catastrophe
non vous n'y croyez pas et puis vous
avez vous avez la tenue de ski de la
tenue normalement il ya toujours un mec
sur un plateau qui a toujours cette
tenue du festival jusqu'au mais une
[Rires]
mauvaise pour le clip il a étonné la pac
de l'ue que régisseur électro et électro
sous tu veux pas qu'ils se battent une
banda j'ai l'impression qu'au niveau des
mers il manque un truc à tant qu'enjeu
pallem sur ses mousquetons jodel à des
muscles tout simplement j'adore
nous devons continuer bien sûr hashtag
toc toc toc tpm paix et vous nous dites
qui est le meilleur pour 1/100 pouvez
nous dire qu'ils étaient tous qu'est
plus mauvais au sol a dit nous parce que
je pense qu'on va être d'accord vous et
moi quand je lui ai déjà dit hashtag toc
toc toc merci à wisches ah ça oui chakim
toi c'est la productrice et c'est pas
elle est magnifique je dis ça oui chaque
imam finance pas moi la première connue
à wisches à 1 à wisches assez bon tiens
tiens suffit mission elle veut dire aux
membres
attention c'est parti la prochaine et je
ne le sont pas mais pas du tout
attention c'est parti
cgg à qui j'ai oublié delphine wespiser
si vous l'avez pas reconnu les chéris
juste non mais attendez deux minutes
c'est la meuf en fait tu veux la porte
plus long la pub a dit je vais faire je
vais faire delphine wespiser sais qui tu
es là c'est qu'ils caire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci metella metella et il faut mettre
les titres après derrière alors j'ai
je
je vous dise je la mets numéro un pour
l'instant pascal astruc déjà
esthétiquement c'est magnifique mais
voilà elle a quand même la coiffure de
laurent ruquier l'esbf mais ça rigolait
la marque halal a beaucoup de routiers
et elle est quand même belle franchement
delphine bravo merci et déjà pour sa
déjà laissé dit et puis elle s'est
battue c'est vraiment la meuf elle a
perdu les deux premiers sets au tennis
mais elle est quand même là ce marché la
veille bravo beinheim vous avez mis une
boulette en dessous de vous quoi
pourquoi vous êtes vachement autres
arabes ans passé je sais pas c'est mon
côté la classe très attention pour
l'instant vous nous dites bien sûr h tac
toc toc toc qui est le plus nul et qui
est la meilleure
forrester moss delphine je le mets
numéro un attention c'est parti à well
as in qatar là c'est là ont des moments
on enchaîne mal c'est parti
toc toc toc jean-michel mais là bas mais
non et comment mais c'est pas ça alors
on refait et octobre
anwar al wardi alors seynois iny
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
[Musique]
non
et jean bie bon là soit tu es mon
préféré tuer numéro alors les mecs ça
fait combien de temps que fait la télé
ensemble pas le melon innovant mais
qu'est ce que vous regardez comme
regarder la caméra et ma caméra ou la
voile elles sont là mais les faits sont
là avec trois pas bon mais oui mais oui
mais vous n'aimez pas possible sans
rigoler on va sauver numéro un rabot il
avait été bon et la petite tape sur
l'épaule
c'est le petit bonus ouais j'ai besoin
de mon poing dans la gueule tu as un
club plus bonus parti parti qui n'a non
mais ça c'est quelqu'un qui énerve et je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui aurait pas
dans le skate c'est quelqu'un qu'il veut
même pas dire toc toc toc c'est
quelqu'un qui est mort ce qu'explique et
la tarte tatin qui est serra qu'elle
rate quelque chose en nous de tennessee
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses mains
pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à quelque chose
m
[Applaudissements]
des pâtés rugby en fait vous n'aura pas
donné pas très bien mais ça n'irait pas
la côte est blond à vous êtes très très
belle bravo vous n'êtes pas première
pour l'instant c'est toujours jean mi
pour moi a apprécié les téléspectateurs
qui vont choisir mais y'en a été très
mois arrivait bien sûr ya maxime ya
daniel zappelli à matthieu delormeau
quoi âgées reconnaît là bas j'ai reconnu
dès demain on voit que c'est des mains
voilà allez c'est parti
quand encore il s'agit du tonique et
cognitif johnny ti chrono mais oui pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait caca dans votre remettez la pesée
l'argent fou
m
là
fait de moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention nouveauté toc toc toc toc toc
kaieda aude autrui au delà de nos
différences
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les coudes et à
échanger nos silences
[Musique]
la seule ans
des fois ça va
[Musique]
alors daniel vous êtes parent première
n'est pas dernière vous avez tout donné
et en tout cas je suis super et c'était
mon premier toc toc toc mairie sachez le
ce sera certainement pas moi vous ne
montrez pas connu un bond important de
l'aide
attention ces 3 5 octobre c'est parti ah
non mais aurait dallas attendez attendez
déjà tu arrêtes de gueuler mais le
talent et après leur entrée sur vannes
auquel gueule déjà déjà refait doucement
à perdre il ne peut pas vous garder sous
la main si tu prends ta mob tu prends
tes jag et on veut plus trop noir pour
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi numéro à ces gens me pour l'instant
et voilà les bravos et et franchement
vous remercierez igor et grichka
bogdanoff de vous la voir attention
c'est le dernier
toc toc toc s'est dégagée de la moto la
qua non non tu peux dégager
non mais je crois il a hélas je tenais
vers une île agence même pas non et
qu'il est ancré ice est pas encore là ça
promet cette collègue il est ancré à la
whey il en créera il se sent bien
pas mal elle sera le dernier toc toc toc
est-ce qu'il est comme un hymne anti
nazi ok j'y mets mamane fois le cul
[Musique]
alors tabac nikki qui est là c'est yves
pour mai
euh vouloir pour tous ceux donnés me
sent très seul
[Applaudissements]
et
haga
tu as
ma
alors là bravo bravo à lui est ce que
vous êtes un petit mot johnny ah oui je
suis très très heureux aujourd'hui juste
vous êtes mal on apprenait que c'est
mathieu d'anjou
vous avez été médaillé olympique de fond
de court
[Rires]